we are seeing
harry and megan do something that hasn't
actually been done
i think it's a case of the palace
watching and waiting to see what they do
and they will be watching and they will
be watching very closely that's royal
expert katie nichol
telling et how queen elizabeth and the
royal family
feel about prince harry's new la
lifestyle
on wednesday et learned that the 35 year
old and his wife megan markle
signed with the harry walker agency for
speaking engagements
i think there is a sense of trepidation
about the couple going
at making a business alone and
you know this they are testing the
waters and i think anything that smacks
them cashing in on their royal
connections
or over commercialization um is going to
meet a very prickly response at the
palace but i think
megan and harry are thinking very hard
about what they want to do
how they're going to make money public
speaking is absolutely going to be
one of the key ways for them to make
money but i think they're going to be
very careful
about what they speak publicly about and
it's certainly not going to be
about life behind the palace walls i
hope that helps you
understand what it had come to that i
would step
my family back from all i have ever
known
just take us to take a step forward into
what i hope can be a more peaceful life
well i think the speaking engagements
have the potential
to earn them hundreds of thousands of
dollars if not
you know into the millions of dollars if
you look at the obamas
who are also signed to the harry walker
agency
and by the way who the sussex is um
really look up to
i understand that the obama's business
model is something that they are trying
to
um replicate then i think they are
potentially able to earn a huge amount
of money barack obama
he has earned 1.2 million dollars
reportedly for giving just
three speeches so this is big money this
has big earning potential for the
sussexes they've been in la since
march um they left the royal family at
the end of
march and as yet they haven't actually
earned anything
so they need to make money and this is a
very lucrative way of doing that
last year when my wife and i attended we
knew we were expecting our first child
um no one else did at the time but we
did and
i remember
sorry they're going to have huge star
appeal don't forget that since arriving
in la
the city has been on lockdown they
haven't been out and about
that first big public appearance when it
comes
is going to be worth a lot of money i
think that public speaking is
is going to be a major source of their
income their sussexes have made it very
clear that they don't want to be doing
commercial deals which may be seen to be
tacky of course they are still members
of the royal family
they're going to be very careful that
they
are not accused of cashing in on their
royal connections
um and if they are doing public speaking
engagements then
they are relatively safe they'll be
talking about the things that are
important to them
racial equality mental health gender
equality the sort of topics that they
are using to define themselves
we start together for the rest of our
lives so
this is true togetherness togetherness
yeah i think
there's always a tendency in the media
to try and incite competition between
the two couples but i think what stands
out to me so much is that we are really
seeing harry and megan
do work that is quite different to the
traditional
royal engagements that we're very used
to seeing william and kate doing
and this is now their opportunity to put
their own
stamp on on their future what we're
seeing
is megan and harry putting down roots in
la this is this is the long term for
them it's why they've signed up with the
harry walker agency
you know when they do launch themselves
in la i think it's going to be with a
bang
and you know they they want to make an
impression
they want to make this work
you